[Music]
the main line
crisis see it's a good name
the main line what's it called when you
get like an experimental dosage
i know a clinical trial
a clinical trial clinical trial there
you go yeah i think that could work
actually placebo no sibo
am i wrong in thinking that's just so
overrated
people are saying we should be you have
to be worried about them like
they don't think deeply enough about
anything to be like
we're gonna renew some like
traditionalist movement
he's busy like snorting coke on
someone's yacht
it's almost like the pr the purpose of
like the more right-wing kind of theory
is like so they don't have to think
about it too much because it's like
like if you distill like ann rand's like
philosophy
like it's basically a philosophy of just
like don't even think about theory
it's just objective reason and
yeah and like and that was actually
pretty explicit and uh earlier
no saying that was actually very
explicitly an injunction in early
conservative theory people like joseph
de maestro
uh throughout his work basically
insisted that the biggest problem
uh in society is that too many people
were encouraged to question
basic presuppositions about why the
world worked
and rather than doing that did you treat
it uh um
let's put it religious dogma and accept
what authority tells them
i wonder if there's been some kind of
slippage between that idea
of like don't basically don't think
critically and crisis
because we know that crisis and crit
critique have the same etymological
roots
they both go back to the greek word
crine or
i don't know how to pronounce it crenin
it means to separate in order to make a
decision
so we get the word crisis and we get the
word critique from the same route
sorry so i just started recording now i
don't know if you guys have been
recording on your own devices this whole
time yeah
yeah i'm recording okay i just started
three minutes in now
well you know eric and i have been
pumping out the the content on the dl
oh yeah the systems theory and
cybernetics
pumping each other on the dl yeah yeah
secret rendezvous yeah sorry honestly i
just
i already deal with like enough [ __ ]
messages all day long i don't need to
like i
was like i can't just add another one
and be like consistent on that
i want to i try i try timing it now
every now and then but it's just
a [ __ ] huge time sink wait what you
don't even pay attention to our group
chat the discord
no i do go on the discord and every now
and then i pay attention to it i'm just
saying
i don't pay as much attention to it as i
should because like it's
at some point or another i'm like
[ __ ] dealing with like messages just
takes up like a huge a healthy chunk of
my day
yeah yeah i haven't i haven't had much
time to go on the discord lately but i
i'm the same kind of
yeah have you seen all the art that's up
in the discord
now yeah that photographer dude has like
some really nice photos
shout out to you for sure ian yeah those
are good
i think who's the the other guy was
posted some photographs too they both
they both know their their cameras and
their stock and erickson
yeah i just maybe just take pictures on
my phone or on my fujifilm
yeah he got i remember there's some good
ones like right after the election or
maybe just before of like protesters he
got some action shots in like dc i think
that was ian
those were cool yeah he's got some
pretty ballsy looking shots there too
that's pretty cool i like it anyway so i
don't know are you gonna our
pills are you going to like introduce
this topic or what are we doing here or
is this happening
what's happening here anyone going to
set the anyone can anyone set the uh
stage i'm feeling like responsibility
anxiety so
do you want me to do it i don't know i
mean [ __ ] hey why don't you
let's mix it up it was your idea there
you go you've been volunteer
i've been volunteered okay
this is weird okay um
yeah and i'm like i'm like clamming up
here i like don't know what to say all
right
welcome everybody to the plastic
pills podcast otherwise known as the
pill pod
where you can hang out with us and
microdose on beer
unless you're matt matt's uh looks like
you got a
a giant vodka a giant tonic
that is huge it is in a beer mug
so today we're talking about if you hear
matt get a little slurry at the end it's
because he's drinking a stein
yeah and who knows how how how many
shots you put in there
well it was a healthy amount let's just
put it that way
he's trying to get through marking and
this is the only way to do it properly
yes so i guess i could just say that
like this week's
unstructured pill pod was inspired i
guess by
something i've been thinking about
lately which is just the category crisis
and how it
like it's instantiated in theory how
like crisis is kind of invoked
as a driver of like or like a way of
defining
moments right because i think a lot of
critical theory talks about the moment
and describes the different phenomenon
society
like technological changes like changes
to
like social mores cultures economics
right and like oftentimes this is
conceptualized
uh among the category or under the
category of crisis
uh and i just think that that's like an
interesting thing to to dwell on and in
some ways maybe 20th and 21st century
philosophy is
you know largely been identified as a
time of crisis or it's been described as
a time of crisis maybe that's not true i
mean maybe every
philosopher has talked about their own
time as crisis i don't know if kant was
he talking about a crisis
in uh in at that time i'm not i'm not
sure but
that's the basic topic and the
definition to look at the meaning of the
word
and that's a good way that's a good
place to start yeah does anyone anyone
got an engram up of uh crisis
i mean compared to like the crises of
capitalism
the boom and bust falling right of
profit and all that husserl's big issue
was like oh [ __ ] science
is no longer based on uh transcendental
phenomenology
we have a crisis in science yeah he
wrote something called the crisis of
european sciences and transcendental
philosophy i actually think that's a
really interesting book though because
one of the features that you find in it
is this real anxiety that the empirical
sciences or the research sciences
aren't based in any sufficiently firm
philosophical foundation
right yeah but if you're going to call
that a crisis i mean well that's what i
mean
they've been doing fine never listening
to who's cyril no well that's exactly
it right i mean uh my brother-in-law is
in quantum theory right he's doing his
bhd you all met him and
from hanging out with a lot of those
people they could not give a rat's ass
about the philosophical foundation some
of them do
as kind of a matter of interest and
intellectual curiosity and stuff but
it's exactly what pills just did right
we're doing fine
uh you know ontological questions that's
nice but
you know what it's for other people who
have time to waste on that kind of stuff
that's that kind of mentality yeah so i
guess what you're identifying there is
what like like husserl's sense of crisis
would be what epistemological crisis
or i think his real sense of crisis
comes around
saying um the sciences are no longer
meaningful
for everyday life which makes sense
with regard to his phenomenological
approach the
european sciences are beco and
mathematical
sciences are becoming purely
positivistic
this was a joke by the end he thought
this was a crisis
and it's fine it's fine yeah exactly i
mean
i mean it well no but i think that
that's actually like a revealing joke
because to some extent like part of what
i had in mind when i was thinking about
this was i do sometimes think that
the category of crisis is like overused
by theorists and philosophers it's like
they want to identify more things as a
crisis to maybe
you know make their inquiry seem more
grandiose than really it is
to some extent or or identify something
as like oh we're living in these
you know and i wonder if it's just also
related to
the broader tendency in human nature to
want to feel like we're living in the
end times or something or some
significant point of point in time
there's like some kind of a cognitive
bias towards thinking that
so it might be related as well to that
if you've ever sat on a review board for
like a conference
every single submission has the word
urgent in it
we have an urgent need to reconsider
the the uh
post liminal spaces pressing issues
the post liminal topologies of animal
human hybrids in hentai
you know world saving [ __ ] yeah
well speaking of conferences maybe
remember i sent you that that call for
papers
uh like that was about crisis that i
just saw i
i think it's an interesting topic i
might even submit a submit a uh
an abstract for it it's like a ucla
political theory
thing maybe i'll post a link to this do
you want to read it in the chat here
i can read i'll read some of it i'm
going to post it uh right now in the
chat so you guys can uh
can have a look at it but yeah it's it's
it's you you thought it was funny
man no it's like we need to change the
world right now and we're going to do it
in this hotel lobby okay okay
i should say also victor you probably
experienced this as well that like um
one of the things that political
theorists or political commentators
and cultural commentators really do when
they don't actually know how
or why they want to change something
it's just by saying it needs to be
radical change
right radical is basically substitute
word for we don't know how we don't know
why
we're not exactly sure but it's got to
be big and transformative because
otherwise it just doesn't seem urgent
enough yeah
or like a radical rethinking of you know
exactly
radical rethinking that's in the
subtitle of every paper
yeah a radical thinking radical
reconsideration of
the semiological positionality of owning
potted plants
so in any case yeah i can read some of
the why don't i start by reading the
first paragraph of this call for papers
and we'll see if that
uh stimulates some discussion here so
okay
it's called uh yeah i guess it doesn't
have it's just the first annual ucla
graduate conference in political theory
and it's like
the vocabularies of rupture and
continuity often taken to be
incompatible
are well known to political theorists
claims of crisis and catastrophe abound
whether technological ecological social
or political
those uh attuned to these exigencies
increasingly reject incremental change
advocating a forceful transformation of
our modes of life
material surroundings and relationships
to each other outside academia
nationalists resurgence says challenge
the continuity of
a globalized world installing border
regimes that rupture the movements of
goods and persons
airwaves and print media fill with
constant complaints of polarization
fears that ideological enthusiasm could
could rupture
time-honored political norms however
vocabularies of rupture
can belie an appreciation for the
continuities
of political life that's only halfway
through the paragraph
i'm done all the verbosity of uh any
academic
writing so continuity and rupture
i guess crisis is associated with
rupture and it seems to be positioned as
like a
uh a discontinuation of of
our traditional norms and values and
ways of doing things
i mean when one of the biggest crisis
like a crisis of meaning
come from nietzsche and nihilism and the
death of god
that seems to be one of the sort of
overarching
philosophical crises of the 20th century
i also want to point out the kind of
unusual elective affinity between these
moments of rupture
that are theorized on particularly by
materialist philosophers
and theoreticians uh and like an older
prophetic tradition that you find in
many of the model theistic phase right
whether
it's the idea of divine or messianic
intervention
and it's unusual because a lot of
vocabulary the sensibility
and the kind of metaphysical
connotations are the same and the only
people who i can think of who've
theorized on the commonalities between
these two vocabularies
would be somebody like walter benjamin
um
to a lesser extent somebody like alan
beggier right now where he talks about
these kind of pauline reactions to
events and so on and so forth
yeah um i think you know it's uh
maybe worth quickly just just uh you
know the
second paragraph of this uh call for
papers like kind of giving their main
message they're like we seek to rethink
the assumed antithesis
of rupture and continuity as the
question below suggests continuity and
rupture are mutually generative in some
cases
in some cases um well in others they're
transposable at specific sites with a
neatness that should make us question
their relations so i guess like the
whole idea is
maybe rethink uh and again maybe a
radical rethinking of like
a dichotomy between those two things and
just to take a step back
how many real crises
have there been that we needed academics
to come help us rethink
yeah i mean i mean i think you know it
makes me think a little bit of you know
covet obviously is a little bit of a
crisis and it makes me think back to the
aragambin episode
right where in some ways you know the uh
a theory
a certain theoretical apparatus a
certain theoretical arms
uh by a gambin are used and he wants to
put them
on to the current crisis and describe
them on those terms
and it seems like his theoretical
arsenal is kind of designed to talk
about
forms of crisis right like states of
exception yeah
um but i think in that case i don't know
if we all came to an agreement at least
but my takeaway
from it was that he was a little bit
hasty there you know rather than looking
at what was happening he wanted to
describe it with his
particular theory uh crisis arsenal
well we gotta sell books right yeah yeah
i mean everything's a crisis feminists
they're a crisis
because they're trying to emasculate
western men
a crisis of masculinity right right
another one
every everyone goes through crises in
their life everyone goes through the
midlife
crisis and the identity crisis there's
personal crisis and there's
also more broad like social crisis and
ecological crisis
it's not like crisis is
something really rare it seems like it's
something that's always around
and the yeah again the deep meaning of
the term really like
etymologically it means like a point of
decision like a point you come to where
a crucial decision needs to be made like
a turning point
or a crossroads and that seems to be
like almost like neoliberal society
wants to deny
that there's ever a crisis that like
business as usual
right even this covid you see posters
around saying like let's get back to the
old normal let's get back to business as
usual right
like this crisis is just a uh it's just
a blip it's just a hiccup nothing's
really going to change it's all it's all
a sort of
show and an illusion and we just need to
get back to normal which
which is something we we should not want
we should not want to get back to the
old
normal or at least most of what went
along with it because the old normal
sucked
this this new normal sucks but the old
normal sucked too
we need a radical how about a third
option
how about a how about a third option you
can't regard i think express this really
well and i'll draw on like
jesus interpretation of him where he
made exactly the point that you're
making right which is that
in one's personal life right the thing
about crisis is that it reveals your
freedom to you
right because most of us you know tend
to like to fall into
bad faith presuppositions that
everything that we're doing is
determined by forces that are beyond our
control right well you know
i can't really get ahead because you
know my job i can't really get ahead
because i'm not making enough money i
can't get ahead because
you know my wife and my boyfriend suck
or whatever happens to be and
when you find yourself in a crisis it's
something where you realize that you do
actually have the freedom to act
right uh you have the freedom to act by
getting rid of all those things or by
trying to rejuvenate them
in a certain way and a lot of people are
afraid and they run away from it
right and g-jek makes exactly the same
point when it comes to social phenomena
and the way that eric was just
describing
right a lot of the times ideology tends
to insist that
there's a necessitarian logic that
underpins everything which means that
the world has to stay exactly the way
that it is and it's only
in moments of crisis that we realize
that actually
everything is contingent and up for
grabs and we can remake the world if we
so desire
and we don't have to accept the kind of
in this case neoliberal injunction that
there is no alternative to the system
the way it is which is precisely why
the kind of ideological gesture that you
see in times of crisis is to try to deny
that it is crisis
now to suggest that it can be managed
using the conceptual
uh and institutional tools that are
available
well now that we're getting serious i'd
like to reiterate my position
that such that if anyone is trying to
sell you
their books or get hired to sell books
and they're talking about a crisis you
can probably dismiss that as
artificially generated
the entire news media apparatus all the
pundits
um academia or at least humanities
academia
as a whole any time they say it's a
crisis
they're probably trying to sell you
something but so is there anyone
is there a crisis of like rhetorical
hyperbole or something like that yeah i
would say so
we need to radically rethink rhetorical
hyperbole
in the academy crisis of rhetoric
well it's funny though like that like i
feel like we all fall into this like so
much it's hard not to and like yeah
it's kind of interesting to think about
like someone like stephen pinker who i
really don't don't like very
much but it is telling maybe i brought
did i bring this up in like a previous
episode but it's related to this
too that like you know we're so attached
to like other academics when pinker
tries to write a book about how things
are actually better and that we're not
in a crisis and that things are getting
better like people were angry
at him like people like like hated him
for saying that like things are getting
better because like we're so attached to
like this discourse of crisis now don't
get me wrong
i i do not agree with pinker uh that
much i think he's missing a lot but
it's still kind of funny to me the way
there's like a visceral reaction to like
an anti-crisis discourse yeah i mean
those arguments like things are getting
better like they're a little bit
shitty i think i mean oh yeah what other
like
obviously there's throughout history
people have had trouble feeding
themselves
but like what business do we have in the
21st century
with so much of the planet being in
abject poverty
and struggling to meet their caloric
requirements so they don't develop
nutritional deficiencies and
developmental issues
like what that those sorts of things
have no business
being in the 21st century never mind the
20th century
yet we allow these things to persist in
the name of denying
that any important decisions can be made
there's no crisis don't worry the system
whatever you think of it the free market
or your your planned economy or whatever
the system is that you're embedded
in will take care of things you don't
have to worry
you know keep calm and carry on right
that's the
that's the message that the so-called
political elite want to send
so that not too many people start to
participate in this decision-making
process that we
as purveyors of crisis and catastrophe
are trying to work people up into
participating i have a complete
agreement with eric
particularly about the anti-neoliberal
stuff right yeah i think i say
more power to it right i think that
victor raises an interesting point here
though which is that
rhetorically and aesthetically uh and
i'll just
leave it at that right i can't actually
think of any academic book i've ever
read
that offer shall we say a positive
appraisal of things as they are
you know what i mean there's no academic
book i've ever read that's like looking
at the data
looking at the situation or reviewing uh
you know
society as it stands right now things
are moving pretty well you know a few
tinkering a little tinkering around the
edge is
uh what we find really the only book of
critical theory i could think of that
adopts
even a moderately positive appraisal of
things as baudrillard's
kind of ecstatic embrace of hyper
reality right and that's almost a fetus
where he says like we have no choice
uh this is the world we live in right
now so we might as well just all
sit there and enjoy the toboggan ride go
moving downhill
i'm gonna need a citation for that uh
this was like uh particularly in his
1990s work when he was talking about
disneyland and stuff he was yeah but
he's never
positive he's just bemoaning it just
saying that this is what i'm saying
it's the closest that i've ever seen a
book come where he's just like
there's really no fighting this any
longer so we might as well just embrace
it to the extent that yeah
it's that nietzschean affirmation right
like [ __ ] the loss of meaning we just
need to
affirmatively embrace life
sorry was it wasn't rory who also like
like like advises people to adopt this
like ironic attitude or something
because things yeah i don't know it
reminds me what you're saying to like
what rory says about that
exactly like apparently was taken to
disneyland and
he was showing like euro disneyland
basically where there's like a little
village where like all the different
european communities are represented
in this extremely hyper real and
stereotyped way and people were looking
at him basically being like isn't this
awful
and he was like no it's great you know
what i mean normally i'd have to get on
a train to go to belgium uh
or you know i'd have to get in a flight
and go to greece and now i can just walk
through the whole continent it's all
readily available to me
you know the food is better and cheaper
you know and
they select you know the most the best
things from each culture what's not to
like about disneyland right
i love the image of this old french
intellectual on some kind of princess
teacup ride with his arms crossed just
looking around
like [ __ ] smoking yeah like
he said the horror of disneyland was the
parking lot because uh you
believe you can go home from it
yeah that's fine so i was thinking
also there's a you know one one of the
more
um i don't know pervasive or especially
i guess
when post-modernism was kind of becoming
in vogue in the 90s and you know still
people talk about this
you know crisis of meaning right like i
think that's a
that's like maybe the overarching um
like crisis discourse that would that is
often talked about i guess especially in
like political theory circles
but i also i'm reminded of like sort of
a feminist
challenge to that whole discourse
especially like in the post-modernism
i'm reminded by um my professor
geraldine finn
and my undergrad i remember she used to
raise you know the observation and sort
of the from the feminist perspective
challenge of those discourses
you know that it's like here we are 20th
century and we have all these
men you know bemoaning all this like
crisis of meaning and how like you know
every like
my my rootedness is dissolving
underneath me and
i guess her question was always like
well crisis for who
right it's like whose crisis is this and
like i think that in general that's an
important question to ask which is just
like
when you make these grand sweeping
statements as
she would say you know these men like to
make these grand sweeping statements
about things right and it's like
well who are we talking about who's the
people experiencing this crisis of
meaning right it's like
and her argument would be like well it's
mostly these these men who are like sad
about i don't know
all these things changing and of course
at the same time you're seeing women get
all these
increased rights and participation in
the society yeah like star wars roles
i don't get it exactly anyway that's
exactly what i heard
victor i like that exact thing if you if
you search uh go
go search um like claire colebrook and
carrie wolfe
talking about the anthropocene they talk
about
that is a crisis too and they bring up
the exact same thing like a crisis for
whom for whom it is a crisis
exactly that's i think that's a key
question when we make these when we have
these discourses
yeah just to go rip off of that and to
talk about another kind of
niching embrace uh of nihilism right a
feminist series that i really tend to
like
um and admire someone like donald harway
right and her cyborg manifesto
uh or one of the points she says is that
like why would you want to live in a
universe that's saturated with meaning
right a universe saturated with meaning
is an aristotelian universe where
you have a purpose that you're meant to
fulfill and you have to fulfill it and
you have no choice right
uh what we have right now is a
meaningless universe where you can
recreate yourself as absolutely anything
that you want to be
right which is why at the end of her
book she says the problem with feminism
is precisely that it opens up these
possibilities
and the future is therefore cybernetic
right the recreation of the self
uh by someone who doesn't know what
their self is and she
closes her book by saying i'd rather be
a cyborg than a god because a god still
lives in this arizonian universe
and has his or her role to play whereas
a cyborg
is a definite potential into a sweeping
future
i like that are you trying to get me are
you trying to get me a little aroused
there i feel it
oh always i was [ __ ] like practically
you know [ __ ] you know directing that
just at you baby
have that highlighted you had that page
bookmarked with a condom didn't you
i did yeah and you know there's a little
like eric tate with love
and parts so do you do wait wait
so do you think it's is haraway maybe an
example of a more optimistic
critical theory i mean if you've even
called it this is what i'm getting in
and this is why i sometimes like her
right because
a lot of the stuff that i imbibe is
about this crisis of meaning like you
victor right it's like oh you know we
live in a nihilistic we live in a
you know pessimistic era and this is all
terrible and so on and so forth and
what she gets at kind of from a feminist
angle but like a posthumous feminist
angle is like
what's really wrong you know with this
crisis of meaning right
uh i mean first off you know women never
felt tremendous amounts of meaning
in their life uh relegated as they were
to second to third class citizens who
and their sole job being essentially to
live and act for someone else
right so that's a big thing that they
bring up uh but she says you know on the
more general point right we now entered
into a cybernetic era where we can
recreate ourselves with these kind of
promethean subjects if you will
uh and isn't that exciting right and she
says think about greek myth right in
greek
myth uh you know essentially prometheus
dara to challenge this aristotelian
universe by bringing fire to man
uh or humankind i should say right and
the goth punished him for it and
rescribed
the teleological order of being right
yeah and said then chain him up off the
rock and she says
now you know we've unleashed them again
right and
this is kind of horrifying in some ways
but it's also extremely exciting and
like exciting and
creative uh in a certain manner right do
you feel excited and creative
i do i mean at points i think that it's
kind of interesting i do like i mean
in between bouts of depression though of
course yeah
i don't get depressed i don't get
depressed sorry oh um
mr iron i mean not not seriously not
serious not seriously depressed really
much at all unless it's you it's always
directed at something um
like if there's something concretely
shitty going on in my life but
victor's got like simon and garfunkel on
loop being like i am a rock
you mean you don't feel like the girl's
mood
of angst like you're a world of
appearances
no you you're not really you fall asleep
as soon as your head hits the pillow
every night
no no but no but not but not because i'm
anxious just because like i'm like
thinking about [ __ ]
like uh like but not angsty [ __ ] just
like other [ __ ] but yeah of course
maybe i'll have like a moment of
existential angst every now and again
but it doesn't weigh on me much
i i did want to pick up on one other
thing that um that matt was saying
just like it is interesting to think
about god killed him
yeah victor is dead what happened
you can continue oh i have i had in it
there's that one of those intermittent
failures hopefully it doesn't come back
but uh okay you guys are hearing me now
yeah
okay so what i was just what i was gonna
say i want to pick up on what matt was
saying a little bit just
the question of of what is a crisis
of meaning specifically and i think like
when you were talking about hairway
you bring up a good point in general
which is like what does it mean to have
a meaning
like not in crisis and i think it's you
know
meaning is like some other like
overarching
meaning structures that tell us what to
do in a way it's like
it's like it's in some ways like meaning
is like i want someone else
or some other force to tell me what i
should be doing and it's like now that i
don't have that
i feel in crisis and it's kind of i
think it's worth
dwelling on just like because when you
say crisis of meaning it
feels like more grandiose but really
it's like i'm
angsty and sad because i don't have
anything telling me what i should do
and it's like i think it's more grounded
to to talk about it in that way
i just cut out again didn't i yeah you
did a little bit we got the recording
so okay so wait wait though listen to
like this is um
bouncing off of charles taylor's secular
age
argument you would feel like you were
being told what to do
but that's because you're post crisis
you're post secular
already but do you think that like uh
a 17th century i don't know shoemaker
just
a nice a nice chill job do you think
that he
thinks god is telling him what to do or
do you think he just feels like he's
fulfilling
god's purpose in his world maybe god's
looking out for him
uh while he makes his shoes and he's
kind of chill in that in
the in the way that a post nietzschean
subject with the weight of the cosmos
placed on his shoulders to create his
own apparatus for meaning
wouldn't feel that way actually i want
to interject on this because
the new book that i'm writing with other
victor um
from the introduction yeah
uh our frequent collaborator right
because one of the things that i think a
lot of conservative
critics uh of post-modernity and our
kind of
hyper-real universe miss is the fact
that a lot of the roots of our modern
crisis of meaning can be found in the
christian tradition
right uh and this is something again i
think that people like zizek
uh or even like other candy uh
christian theologians like paul tillich
pick up on right because
what you see with christianity is a
really
interesting phenomenon where the central
figure in the tradition
uh is a god who comes to doubt himself
uh on the cross right
and then dies right and symbolically one
way that can be interpreted is of course
that
god is saying i'm passing away from this
existence and i am now on
giving you the authority to remake my
creation as you see fit
right um and this is what you know jesus
contributed it's the way that people
like paul tyler occasionally interpret
it isn't what happened in the bible
well no it does actually because no i
mean this isn't what my
my austrian shoemaker believes
of course not but again this is one of
the points that i think um people like
tilik
and um zg are trying to bring up right
is that it's important not to let
christianity off the hook
for its own role in generating this
crisis of meaning because it had a
profound impact on
what might broadly call european
civilization as a whole so when
conservative critics now bemoan
the fall of christianity it's important
to recognize in a dialectical manner
that
christianity had the inner potential to
wind itself down towards something like
the death of god
right that's not a break it's in some
senses
a contingent but nonetheless possible
root uh that the christian tradition
could have taken
and there are resources within the bible
that you can look to which show
why this would what's happened right the
most obvious one again being the fact
that
jesus died said you know god why have
you forsaken me uh that he ascends into
heaven and says well
it's now up to you you know you deal
with it you know what i mean
my sense of it would be something more
like
christianity created the first singular
polar hinge for meaning everything that
is meaningful
comes from god anything that doesn't
come from god is not meaningful
whereas any other system had it
collapsed it's
multi-polar in terms of its meaning or
syncretic or whatever so i wouldn't take
the death of god
uh sense that you have because i i don't
know that that sense of loss would have
been widespread but
i definitely think that christianity
absorbing
all meaning unto itself at least in the
western world
and then you know killing god that would
be
much more responsible for a sense of uh
homelessness
yeah very fair yeah what i'm just trying
to say and
i'll fix it as soon as it's done is that
it's important not to let christian
conservatives off the hook by
because they always want to say that wow
what we see now is a break with
christian tradition
you know in the sense of an ordered
parasitic universe
and we need to say no you know if
christianity is foundational to the
western way of thinking about things
then christianity must have played a
foundational role in generating the
conditions that we see right now
you know there are inner potentials
within christian doctrine that led to
this point
and i think you can see that uh with
some of these new interpretations by
materials critics
uh of christianity right by they say
look you know god literally dies
in the christian tradition in every
single one of the gospels and doesn't
just die he sits there and says you know
why have you forsaken me you know oh
lord right
he comes to doubt himself uh and i think
it's important to recognize this
uh rather than give into this reaction
or predisposition to see
everything as some kind of big fall away
from a sacrosanct christian period
uh yeah i also i also think that uh
you know discourses of of of crisis in
academia maybe
overvalue or like over
estimate how much that shoemaker
would actually care about like these
thick meaning structures like it's
really the theoreticians
and like you know the priests or
whatever who are really worried about
this thick
meaning loss it's like that guy just
wants to feel like he's got like family
and friends around
and um and just wants to
continue making his shoes in a way that
like he can but he doesn't care about
like the underlying
meaning like structures you know like
he's not he's not he doesn't have like
a strict sense of like a theoretical
understanding it's just like you know
i'm i i get to live my life comfortably
and i think maybe like the theorists
project
their concern with like you know oh like
if things can't be justified
metaphysically then it's like oh it's
going to be a disaster for these
everyday people
sciences are going to collapse because
they're not based on transcendental
phenomenology
little anti theory there yeah no i
remember though uh
there was some max weber scholar that i
read who
put it really nicely with reference to
your shoemaker uh pills
where i said look you know say you have
franz and he grew up in southern
bavaria right and his father was a black
a blacksmith and his father was a
blacksmith before that and
right and he was going to marry elsa you
know in
you know the black forest and it was
going to be wonderful and all that stuff
but
all of a sudden late 19th century he's
told listen there's no more need for
blacksmiths any longer
uh so you're gonna need to move to a big
city like munich to get a job in the
factory
right so he leaves the town where he's
lived his entire life
and he goes wanders into munich and then
he finds that not only
are there not just uh millions of
germans that he's competing with but
french people are there italians are
there uh
all kinds of businessmen from the united
states even might happen to be jostling
around there
they speak many languages they're not
particularly interested in the kind of
roman catholicism
of his birth uh he's expected to compete
for jobs in an industry where
the actual owner of the business might
change on a semi
uh you know hateful basis right
uh he really feels adrift in the world
uh in a way that his father and his
father's
father might not have right uh and i
think we can all appreciate some of this
and you know to victor's point i think
this is one of the problems with this
notion of
restoring a sense of meaning through
community right i think it's really
difficult to do that under the
conditions of
late capitalist modernity precisely
because there are so many material
practices
uh that kind of compel people to engage
in alienating activities right now so
that's
the one concession to like the kind of
crisis literature that i am sometimes
willing to make
i agree also to victor's point though is
that
meaning in a sense was guaranteed for
this shoemaker
they didn't have to think about it quite
so much because you're
you're in a society where there's a
great chain of being and you have
i don't know a monarch someone at the
top
and that's the person like meaning flows
downwards right from god to the monarch
throughout society from the head to the
body to the parts
and you don't have to think too much
about it but in our in our
20th century 21st century world
where meaning is no longer guaranteed
where where
a lot of people now take the stance that
we live in an essentially meaningless
universe
or in a universe where we're looking at
it like as in existence precedes essence
and that we now have to sort of make our
own meaning and people turn to different
ways they turn to existential philosophy
they turned a new age spiritualism
they turn to historism yeah yeah sure
they just throw themselves into
capitalism they turn to eastern wisdom
and other sorts of
these sorts of ancient traditions and
mysticism mindfulness
yeah and mindfulness and meditation like
people seek
sources of meaning everywhere now and it
sounds like you're summarizing my
youtube channel
yeah no but you're right i mean you're
right i couldn't agree with you more uh
eric i think that's exactly right
but but it does speak back to something
i said earlier which is like so it does
seem like meaning is just someone above
you telling you what you should be doing
or like
like it's like you the king and like
there's meaning is guaranteed it's
because you know
your role yeah you'd be part of like a
little parish community and your priest
would probably tell you
like what the meaningful thing like what
you need to pursue in your life to be a
good person and otherwise you don't need
to think too much about your
soul and your salvation like meaning in
a sense is woven into that
sort of spiritual uh evangelical or
christian kind of structure that you're
embedded in whereas today
it's not so much we're in like a
marketplace of ideas and meanings right
where
where you know you can get yoga is
disembedded from the hindu tradition
and flown over to california where
where hippies practice it while they're
distributing magical stones that you can
put under your pillow and all kinds of
weird [ __ ] that people believe i mean
you just call it lsd eric
i mean conspiracy theory this is a
conspiracy theory is a source of meaning
for plenty of people
as is all the other kinds of crazy
ideologies out there as well
so we can't we have to think intensely
about where we get our meaning or
meaning will
find us it sounds a lot like it sounds a
lot like
like the the literal meaning or whatever
of the word of just like having to make
the decision like having it
having to decide yourself so like it is
a crisis i suppose in that sense because
people have to decide for themselves
yeah and there's a point there's a
reason why we focus on rupture
and discontinuity and crisis is because
those are places where we can go in
as a community and exercise creativity
and perhaps
put things on a new track that's
different than before
and as we'd all hope better than before
and not simply business as usual
as it was before yeah i should say i
also think this is probably why people
like daddy are so popular right now
right i mean yeah he kind of like
synthesizes a lot of this together and
provides you with a little taste of all
of it from across the globe it gives you
a map
of meaning including
the authoritarian structure with 12
rules and now
12 more rules published by his daughter
while he's under duress
beyond chaos oh god
that certifies though that he's going to
try to offer some concession to the
political left though because like
and like an antidote to chaos uh you
know suggests that he's trying to look
for like a more orderly universe or the
type that we've been
kind of you know softly criticizing
stuff uh
a beyond order suggests that maybe he's
now like offering some concessions to
chaos or however it is that he frames it
so yeah i mean he's right to focus on
myth
like that's also a important locus
of meaning that we focus on in critical
theory
and political debates
my feeling about this is not so much
that it's the
authoritarian that we crave necessarily
but more what comes along with myth
which is the community
that believes in the myth perpetuates it
you know develops it tells news stories
and you know when when the market
takes over almost every social relation
that we have
um except for like very minor
communities otherwise everything is just
a market relationship
so there's no incentive to to have
relationships with people that aren't
going to
i guess benefit you financially and
there's no one there to create that
community in place and i'm not saying it
was any different before
it was just there was only one community
to join
yeah or two no the masons
well and there was community available
but i also think you know
to some extent like i'm i'd almost take
it a slight step further and say like
the myths
aren't what matter at all like the
content of it it's just like
i see those things as just a vehicle for
humans to have a connection with each
other and i think that when humans have
connection
they feel better and myth and like
shared things it's just a way of sharing
it's a vehicle it could be anything it's
like we just need something
to get us to to connect with each other
and like i don't think the content
really matters that much that's why
there's so many different religions
in the world like the content doesn't
really matter it's just like a vehicle
for people to
to hang out and feel connected to each
other and feel like they belong and oh
i would go even further than that i mean
if you look at like what's happened
since the 1960s right
people now become connected around
post-modern mythologies right
uh comic book film sci-fi film
harry potter lord of the rings like all
these little micro communities
uh that kind of assemble themselves uh
over what are essentially bricolages
uh of the mythical like uh traditions
past right and
i can kind of understand why i mean i'm
a fan of a lot of these uh franchises
myself so you know i'm speaking from
yeah but no absolutely but yeah like
some cultures
and music right yeah exactly but like
just just to kind of touch on what like
a lot of people are saying here right
like
i do agree with like all um what eric is
sorry what um
hills is saying right that essentially
like the problem is that
there can be a temptation to move
towards authority figures uh in order to
provide this sense of meaning
uh along with the associated
hierarchical structures that you would
think
of when it comes to authority right uh
and i think one of the reasons why it is
that so many reactionaries feel that
there's a crisis of meaning right now
uh is it because there's actually less
meaning in people's lives so that that
might be the case
for some privileged groups uh you know
who kind of vest their identity in a
sense of
significance and having power and
authority right it's that
sources of meaning have been
democratized uh in a way that they never
have before
and associated with this is the need to
kind of create
uh new individuated senses of what's
significant
from groups whose voices we've never
really heard before right
which is precisely why i think that
we're in a promethean age
and what i just really hope is that this
is going to be carried out and
it's going to be a project that's going
to be undertaken democratically rather
than through the auspices
of was fundamentally a very egalitarian
market
right yeah absolutely and i think
but i think it's also the fact that you
have to make a choice
and figure it out for yourself is like
why the more conservative types are
you know there is a temptation towards
the authoritarian figure because it's
like it's the very fact of it of it
being democratized it's the fact of it
being
um that there might not be a right
answer that other people like just
knowing that other people are making
different choices to to build their
meaning around is like
disturbing to like some conservative
conservative mindset where like
the very thing that secures their sense
of meaning was like oh
like i'm on the right path that is like
objectively right and it's like
losing the possibility of it actually
being objective i think
is which makes people tempted towards
the authoritarian figure
i think well instead of acting like
we're outside of this why don't we do a
little bit of
dialectics here and say
us us hanging out
and the listeners that listen to us and
the people that support us we're just
offering
a community based on a myth and a lot of
the time we get stuck in these questions
like
what are we doing what are our politics
for where are they going
maybe we're just making a community to
hang out and we just think that our
myths are better than all the other ones
yeah i i feel that i mean i think that
that's
maybe one of the most uh like satisfying
things about about
how this has been uh unfolding this
podcast and you know
your your youtube channel pills is it is
it's true it's like the meeting the
people
meeting people and like you know it's
made the pandemic maybe feel a little
bit less
isolating is the fact that we get to do
this every week so yeah i mean
i just gives a little more purpose and
purpose is a source of meaning right
that's
the whole the whole thing about the the
midlife crisis is like what have i been
doing with my
life what am i working in a cubicle for
30 years
yeah what have i been doing like like my
life has been meaningless thus far i
need i need a cause
i need to commit myself to something in
order to feel like i'm doing something
meaningful with my life right i need to
i need to help people
i need to write great books i need to i
don't know
feed the hungry i need to make make the
world a better place in some meaningful
way that's
that's that seems like if you're doing
like a
i don't know if it qualifies as
phenomenology but like
like everyone has these questions right
and and
you find your own source of meaning and
it can seem arbitrary
like where you might choose you know if
you go into new age spiritualism or you
go into politics or if you go into some
kind of humanitarian thing
but i think if we take also like a
historical perspective then it doesn't
appear
quite so arbitrary because things have
been
going in certain directions for quite a
long time
and modernity is a is a is a notoriously
difficult place to find meaning and
right especially
especially with when you think about the
rates of of mental illness and suicide
and developed countries
as opposed to other countries it's it's
it's a difficult it's difficult time
well then i would i would also like to
hear of a time where someone didn't go
through a crisis like
when has anyone ever had a whole
generation that didn't experience any
crisis
any kind of anxiety over meaning
or yeah that never happened yeah i think
it's always been
if chris i mean not chris if marx
is right then i think we'd be remiss
not to at least bring up the fact that
uh market relationships
being like the highest and some cases
only form
of relationships is a little bit
different from
from what would have been preceding that
because you know all that is solid melts
into air all that is sacred is
profane if you can believe in anything
it's ironic
because market relationships define
almost every relationship like outside
of the family pretty much
yeah but i also want to just like to add
on to eric's comment in a more humble
way because i think he's exactly right
about this and say that
i come back to my point about
sub-communities right which is uh i
watched a movie recently called
paul uh which is a seth rogen film about
a little alien
and two nerds who decide to quest from
the united kingdom
to california in order to go to what's
basically a star trek convention
right and what struck me about this
movie
is these guys are basically losers by
any kind of conventional
metric right but the movie has a lot of
sympathy for them
and what the reason i liked it is again
there's this real democratic ethos to
the film which is that they find meaning
in this community that they're a part of
that might be kind of
vulgar and not particularly
sophisticated but nonetheless it makes
them happy
you know what i mean and i think that
you're starting to see this more and
more
in the kind of even the pop art of the
time it's reflecting this desire to move
on to a
more democratic approach to systems of
meaning that don't
elevate certain sources of inspiration
uh over others right
uh and i think there are problems with
that but i also think it's a liberatory
uh kind of development uh that's
expressed in the kind of cultural
materials at the time
yeah i think you're i think you're right
and those sorts of subcultures
that people get involved in are
not only a source of meaning but closely
related is
is is to this quest for meaning is
identity right and everybody searches
for an identity
everyone joins communities and
subcultures in order to feel like they
have
some place they belong and they derive a
sense of
self from that right so perhaps perhaps
all of this all of this uh
hubbub over uh over identity politics
and the ways that people try to
articulate themselves
in what's basically some kind of public
discourse is
is part of this search for meaning in
the 20th century and coming into the
21st
and it's something we shouldn't dismiss
anyway even
even though they appear in weird strange
ways and subcultures on the internet
and cosplay and comic book conventions
and we we shouldn't be so
quick to dismiss these sorts of new
forms of of
new ways of being people are adopting
because because i i actually find most
of that stuff pretty cool i'm a
i love video games and i love comics and
movies and all kinds i'm an i'm a nerd
of the sort
too so i i mean i i enjoy that stuff and
i like it when i
can see people having uh having the
freedom to
to choose and i know i know that that
that freedom can also have the opposite
effect of a kind of um
you know overwhelming overwhelming right
like a
we call it like paralysis through choice
too much too much choice but
but i i generally think it's a good way
because because normally
you get your identity from your family
and who came before you
right our our old austrian shoemaker's
probably a shoemaker because the father
was a shoemaker
and some kind of and their last name is
probably shoemaker let's call him
uh mr austrian shoemaker and that's
probably his last name too
and that's that's where your identity
comes from and that's where the
and identity is kind of the bedrock in
which you
found meaning in well he's austrian so
it's schumacher right
schumacher um all right so we've been
rosie oh the internet's such a beautiful
place
uh why don't we look at the dark side of
our
uh what do you call it when you can when
reprobates can gather at the same time
as the rest of us are making nice uh
uh uh furry communities
i know that's the other the exact flip
side of the coin is
you can create meaning around any
sort of uh fabricated artificial
history that you want and if you're
gonna do that then you might as well
say like we have a problem with the
immigrants and that's the problem
yeah if all things are equal then how do
you how do you evaluate
different sorts of different sources of
meaning and different kinds of
identities
you can't you can't really do that
because you have to kind of say they're
all equal
and they're all legit in a certain way
i've said this before i have so much
respect for these
q people though like the creativity that
they have
sort of as a group this emergent
mythology it's
it's the the newest most interesting
thing that we've
we've seen in decades are you mean
people oh yeah
yeah it's beautiful in a way but it's
also a little scary it's like
people taking like lovecraft seriously
like he wrote
non-fiction yeah
no no i agree i mean i think that's
exactly the problem that we're
we find ourselves in right now right
which is that on the one hand
you know as modern and post-modern
subjects right there's something nice
about this democratization of meaning
that's occurring and the fact that
people can now create their individuated
cells and communities without
interference by
you know micromanaging hierarchies that
tend to presume what the best kind of
life will be
and the problem is that not all sources
of meaning may be created equal
right and i'm not actually sure what the
answer to that question is
right because on the one hand i don't
want to sit there and reprimand somebody
who finds a lot of meaning and being
to eric's point you know a video game
fan and finds a lot of meaning in that
community right our star wars fan
i do want to sit there though and
reprimand people who find a lot of
meaning in being white nationalists
or being writing populist or whatever it
happens to be
right it's just unclear to me
what the standard should be uh
yeah i mean learn well we learn well the
lesson from post-modernism that there's
no sort of
objective standpoint you can take on
these sorts of issues
there's no there's no objective basis so
it's not
something you can quantify yeah exactly
isn't there also a play here like you
know this
like i think what some people crave is
like a thicker meaning structure and
then there are some that are more
like content with like you know
spreading their meaning
across things that are that feel
pluralistic like i don't know like
i think part of the thing that made
older meaning structures like i don't
know in the middle ages
um appealing and like you know when i
read someone like patrick dineen talking
about the breakdown
of you know family values like like you
know or
like a sexual revolution and all these
like things you know to me that's just
code word for saying like
for my for me to feel like i have thick
meaning it needs to be premised on some
kind of exclusion
because the thing that makes this thing
meaningful is that
we are this group that are tied and
people who don't want to accept that
should [ __ ] off somewhere else and be
excluded
and i think that that's like you know a
thick meaning structure to me is
premised onyx on some form of exclusion
and saying like there are boundaries
clear boundaries between like what is
part of this and what is not
that's probably sorry i can't see when
you're talking because your video is off
i know oh sorry i was just going to say
if we have like a multi-polar
world also i'm kind of what i was
describing like if you have a monopoler
god is the source of meaning and now
what you feel like is a source of
meaning
then what makes your meaning special in
a world like that would be that somebody
else doesn't have it
or couldn't have it or can't have it or
you can stop them from having it
that's true yeah yeah and in a way you
could only experience a crisis of
meaning when you're in a situation of
of this thickness of meaning right
and i i guess what i mean by thick
meaning you you could think about
like uh if your your grandparents die
and they're
and they're you're inheriting their
objects and maybe something's like a
family heirloom right like
that thing has thick meaning to it
because it's got a story it's got a it's
got a um
what's the what's the word it's been
it's been passed down over the
generations and it's sort of acquired
this meaning
that's nowhere visible as opposed to
like a thin
version of meaning which would almost be
like almost like a linguistic
or a or a semiological kind of
conception of meaning where where just
you know this means this and that's
that's that's all there is to it
but you call it the death of an aura
hmm i would actually like to rip off of
victor's point for a second because
i absolutely agree that there are all
kinds of different groups out there
right now and you know we've talked
about them
we tend to feel that meaning has to be
inherently exclusionary
and that i can't have a sense of meaning
if there are people who essentially
don't adopt my
source of my sense of values uh in the
community that i happen to inhabit right
and the way that i've always responded
to this is it's kind of ironic since a
lot of these people also tend to
characterize our age as inherently
nihilistic precisely because it is so
permissive
so inclusive and so on um but i would
actually turn the tables on them and say
that the most nihilistic people that i
know
are reactionaries right exclusionary
reactionaries precisely because they see
the source of meaning in existence as
being so thin and so fragile
that the presence of any kind of impure
or non-involved part of it
would destroy the whole structure of
significance on which they depend
yeah like star wars we can't we can't
let those girls into star wars
yeah exactly the minute you know a
single woman is going to play rey in the
star wars franchise it just destroys
every all the significance of this
franchise
yeah that's a good point yeah video
games women getting more involved in
video games i mean i don't know why you
defense star wars in the first place
they're all
[ __ ]
there are cute films in it take a chill
pill buddy
yeah yeah let's not sit there and insult
star wars but like you know the thing is
like these reactions have this extremely
nihilistic attitude towards the world
which is like basically
if there's anything in here that
detracts
uh from my ability to enjoy this with
just the people that i want in just the
way that i desire
uh with people who think exactly like me
the whole structure of signification
will fall apart
right and i think one of the things that
we should try to do exactly as nietzsche
would teach in his better moments to say
you need to toughen up and realize that
we live in a pluralistic universe now
where people are going to have
different sources of meaning and rather
than react
viscerally against that like some kind
of weak nihilist
you should embrace it as a
feature of the experimental
experimentation uh
and what it means to be human and the
kind of source of meaning that you
create
yeah i think i think the sorts of
anti-immigration
libertarian types are
one of those exclusionary groups you
were talking about because
they feel maybe that immigrants aren't
going to invest
meaning in the things that they invest
meaning and in the same
way right because that's essentially
what we do in our lives when we're going
about our days and we're thinking about
things as we
we we tend to invest meaning in things
right whether it's in
statues of old confederates or whether
it's in
uh i don't know things we find on the
internet we tend to invest
meaning and we tend to think that
there's a certain
proper way to behave towards those
things and and the
the anti-immigration sentiment is is
kind of a fear that that people are
going to come in and not
not value the same things that we value
and and and then that's going to have
some kind of implication for
for social cohesion but really it's it's
it's a kind of
egotistical kind of selfish fear that
like my
my meaning world my life world as as as
husserl would call it my
my laban's felt is not going to uh
i'm not going to be able to maintain
that i'm not going to be able to
i mean i always love the psychological
terms
uh assimilation or accommodation right
so
when when you encounter something that
the structures of meaning that you
already have in place
are equipped to deal with then all
you're really doing is assimilating it
to the structure that's already
there whereas if something happens
that's
like way out of the ordinary that you
can't sort of deal with without some
kind of dissociation
then you have to accommodate that by
changing
the sorts of meaning structures that you
have in place like it's a much more
fundamental change when we're talking
accommodation instead of assimilation
and i think some people
fear that sort of idea that they're
gonna have to accommodate
new ideas or accommodate new ways of
being
so they so they don't like people moving
into their community who are different
than them people tend to get that
xenophobic outlook which which i really
think
can be solved if you i mean if the if
if you really just encouraged people to
learn and have new experiences then
they'd be less
afraid of difference yeah this sounds
like the
hermeneutic circle that we kind of
talked about with
the heidegger episode yeah it seems like
like a a narrow hermeneutic just leads
to
everything being a crisis right and i
think our
if we have a hermeneutic cycle as a
culture it's trained
by news media to interpret everything as
a crisis
every week is a crisis because if it
weren't a crisis then you wouldn't need
to listen to them to tell you that it
was a crisis
so i think if there's if there's one
thing that we could say about
post-modernism
which i don't usually like to use that
term but it would be of a very
thin or a very small
yeah a very thin or a very small
hermeneutic
where you uh are constantly defending
the fragility
of your your smoky
spectral view of the world and that's
what's worth defending because it's the
last thing you can hold on to
yeah i put it a little bit different way
uh and say that there are two kind of
hermeneutics we could adopt
uh one is a masmitory hermeneutic uh
where essentially
what we need is for everyone else in the
world to essentially
emulate my fantasies and emulate the
sources of meaning
that i think are important right uh
otherwise i'm unable to take enjoyment
uh from the sources of signification
that exist in the world
right or we can have an erotic
hermeneutic uh that's fundamentally
inclusionary
that takes joy and even excitement
from the fact that we have to deal with
the other in a constructive way that
allows them to maintain their difference
while at the same time producing
something greater
as a group that forms a relationship
with one another
uh than anyone can come up with
individually uh and i think again
you see character uh characteristic of a
lot of reaction areas is precisely that
they
are highly dependent on this
masturbatory hermeneutic of existence
right where you know they have to look
into the world and see themselves
reflected into it
uh in every kind of feature of existence
well put all right well before we
before we wrap up an episode on crisis
news media news media i mean they're
still
they're still probably talking about
trump right
i have happily been away from the news
but there we got to be
he's allowed the transition but he's
still denying oh really
okay so it's a another fake crisis
but we'd be remiss if we didn't finish
talking about
eric's thick source of meaning
the crisis of crises
climate positive feedback
oh yeah oh god i know i know i know the
the crisis
the ecological crisis is something but
i didn't want to bash our conversation
over the head with that no it's too easy
i think we gotta at least finish with it
because what makes that different from
every other
you know supposed urgent radical
rethinking required matter
yeah i mean i've i've thought about it
quite a lot
and and it's it's it's difficult
it seems like it's it's it is a unique
kind of crisis it is a crisis among
crises
because it has a definite material
dimension that can't be dealt with
it can't be dealt with by addressing the
same issues that post-modernism and
post-structuralism have been
addressing it through which is almost a
way like a radical rethinking
like it that that term we've been using
like can we just radically rethink
ourselves and the crap and the crisis
will go away
i mean in a sense i mean i'm i'm tempted
to be super inflammatory and just say
like the liberal conception of the human
being
and the human relationship to the world
has been
at the heart of the climate crisis
or at least it's behind it because we've
always
considered like one i don't know maybe
one of these major sources of meaning in
our lives have always been that human
beings are somehow special
and that the rest of the world is
somehow less than human creatures like
not even non-human but just less than
human right like humans are the only
things
that meaning is for and only the things
that can make meaning
right but but that's that is probably
a pathology that's been
in our heads for a long time that's been
contributing to
where we are today in the sense of
i mean unlimited growth and nature is a
standing reserve
and capitalism and those sorts of things
have been contributing to
this yeah this feedback loop where we're
putting more carbon into the atmosphere
than the world can deal with and
it seems to me to require a radical new
approach
different from the other approaches that
we've been using for other things like
like identity and
immigration and refugee people and
a whole slew of other issues that are
also close to us
the ecological crisis seems to be
different because you know you say
like yeah incremental change reform
deliberation but we don't have time for
any of that
yeah we get constant warnings by the by
the
by the ipcc and all those guys saying we
don't have time
we just need to change but we can't
we're addicted to fossil fuels
we love plastic we love buying [ __ ]
all of this stuff is making this climate
crisis
something that's radically different
from anything we've ever faced before
like we always think that like human
beings live on a trajectory which is
always into the future
we live in a progressive forward
movement and that nature is cyclical it
always restores it always comes back
it's always been in that back stop to no
matter how bad we [ __ ] up our society we
can rely on nature being there like a
safety net
almost not in a way because you can be
in nature and abject poverty it's not
going to help you
but in another sense you know if these
ecological services that we've been
relying on
and not thinking about not investing
meaning in
for so long go away well they're going
to come back to bite us in a real
bad [ __ ] way that we better be ready
for and
we're not ready for it and all these
other
all these other crises seem to seem to
me to pale in comparison to what people
are going to be dealing with
in that near the end by the by the end
of the 21st century
it seems and then it's alarmism that's
that's that's the conservative line
that's the that's the neoliberal line
that's the
that's the line it's all alarmism but
i have a feeling it's not and i have a
feeling that
we need to really have a radical new
approach
i need to raise my own alarm because
actually while we were talking one of
the most
significant moments in modern left-wing
history
has occurred because chomsky
and alexandria you're going to say
he's dead no alex idiot cortez and
jug meat have just agreed to play among
us
on twitch together tomorrow oh god and
it's a pairing of the american left and
the canadian left that is virtually
unprecedented
where we're now literally rocketing into
space
baby well i can tell you what i'm doing
tomorrow
aoc is good we need that green new deal
i hope she wins
are they playing against each other i
don't know they are yeah i mean the
whole point of the game is well
you cooperate but one person is a serial
killer and
yeah it's like werewolf eric i think i
invited you to play once yeah
anyway um back to eric's story the the
one
thing that doesn't make sense to whether
you want to call a human
and human society like narratological
like they depend on these meaning
structures
that take place through uh the position
that you put yourself
in in the narrative this thing's alien
to us even though it's probably the only
real crisis that like this
the species will face um
unless you want to count unless you want
to count covid but you can't
put yourself in a narrative that lasts
so far beyond you and so far before you
unless you have a real collective sense
of what humanity is
and i don't know i don't know whether it
was different i have no idea
whether it was different before or
whether it's like uh
big bad liberal individualism that made
us only think
in terms of what you can get out of
something but
we i don't think we have the narrative
resources despite making all these
hollywood films about collapse and
crisis and
and uh what what it's going to look like
after that i don't think we have the uh
hermeneutic i'll say we don't have the
broadness of a hermeneutic required to
even understand
what's happening enough to ever make
anything happen
and i hope someday long to the future
some
some cave dwelling the road guy with a
shotgun
digs digs a hard drive out it's a dark
movie and someone
someone recorded the plastic pills
podcast talking about this and he goes
i wish someone would have listened to
them yeah i mean there's there's
so many patterns of thinking even in the
most
well-meaning and egalitarian liberal
humanism that is not prepared to deal
with the climate issues that we're going
to be facing in the 21st century
it's just not it's just not like even
going back to donna haraway
she points out that if you you know if
you take out
everything in your body that is not
human there's probably going to be about
four pounds of stuff left over like we
rely
not only on the microbiomes and the
other kinds of things that are crawling
around our skin
all the time but we're also like not as
human as we thought we were
because we rely on these ecosystem
services and we're embedded in an
ecology
and that's why like i try to focus on
ecological thinking a little more
because i think
this sort of liberal individualism
has been like it's run its course it's
served its purpose we've got
people are aware of civil rights people
are aware of
the importance of individual freedom and
living in a free society but that's not
enough
like we need a new way of thinking of
ourselves as embedded in different kinds
of systems
not only social but material
and organic systems that we rely on like
so i would say
we don't we don't need it to be our
radical rethinking we just need to you
know following i think what matt's
opinion i'm going to assume is
which is like you know we need to
preserve those things that we like about
liberal individualism but like enhance
them with these other ways
so it's an enhancement of of because i
don't think we want to throw those
things away
um no we want to we want to build on
them but what i'm saying
exactly is in a way they're not enough i
would actually i agree
build upon that by saying that one of
the problems that
faces uh in this environmental situation
is the notion that nature has an
independent teleology to it a kind of
meaning uh that's implicit and goes
beyond the human
and the kind of rhetoric and theologies
that are associated with this is the
notion that
nature is self-correcting right there's
nothing that we can do that's so bad
that it can't revert back
to the way it was before because nature
has some kind of implicit
significance to it that human beings
can't interfere with right
and i think precisely by recognizing
nature and human beings as
artificial creations we can understand
why it is that
everything that is produced is fragile
right including the natural environment
right
we can't just assume that existence is
going to auto correct for anything that
we do to it
well i mean the language of the language
of conservation and preservation that
was brought up earlier is is a nice
start but we've been doing that for a
long time
and it hasn't been working i mean we're
we're on a decline
right species are going extinct
faster than they're coming into being
we're losing the biodiversity of the
planet and that's going to have major
impacts on our health
and our psychological well-being going
into the future
i mean there's just so many different
ways we need to get in
like i can't even do it in the last
section of this crisis video
and like i didn't that's why i just
wanted to focus on
more human centered crises than than
focusing on an ecological crisis because
the
those questions are going to bring us to
the to the to the brink of our humanity
and beyond
and we we're probably not ready to go
there at this
at this late an hour in the day in our
in our
episode here but i i think
i think yeah it's not like incremental
change
the the language of preservation the
language of changing our ways like we're
already
[ __ ] it's not it's not a matter of
preserving what's left
it's just a matter of damage control at
this point like we're already
[ __ ] and the longer we take to realize
that
and the longer we start to think the
longer we keep thinking that like oh
neoliberalism and free market thinking
and being able to spend your money any
way you want is still okay because
that's the part of the liberal tradition
and that's okay
the longer we keep thinking that and the
longer fossil fuels are
allowed to continue to do what they're
doing and
influence politics and i'm seeing biden
loading his cabinet with
lobbyists and fossil fuel people
and all that [ __ ] like the longer we let
this go the harder it's going to be to
address in the future
and liberal humanism is not going to cut
it we need
a liberal post-humanism at least
oh yeah yeah for sure and i think maybe
i was just gonna quickly add
you know maybe uh maybe covet helped a
little bit with the ecological crisis
we'll see
we need to knock a few bodies off the
planet yeah i mean it showed us what's
possible and bruno latour
bruno latour pointed this out it showed
us what's possible because we all said
before we said we can't just stop things
right we can't just stop because the
economy will collapse our supply chains
will collapse and kovids
showed us that yes we can stop this [ __ ]
and yes nature will respond in positive
ways although we shouldn't be too
optimistic about seeing dolphins near
venice or
whatever whatever was happening near the
whatever those news stories that were
popping up near the beginning
we shouldn't put too much stock in those
things because those aren't
you know those are those are news
stories again those are those are media
creations but
but it does show us that things are
possible that
we've been convinced are not possible
we've been
shown that things can change that
you know the so-called elites want to
convince us that can't be changed
yeah nature's teloses are telos and the
nature culture
nature society divide is a creation of
modern man
that is totally maladaptive and [ __ ]
and we need to get rid of it
asap so everybody think about nature
the last thing i wanted to leave you
with is do you ever like do the math and
figure out when you're gonna die
like if it if it comes at the average
age
versus early yeah 20
about 20 70 i'm i'm cashing in i
i'm looking at like i mean based on our
lifestyles uh
i think we're we're probably dead in the
2060s
unless there was an accident but then
the thing is if we have a kid
that kid's gonna make it to uh like 2090
and who knows what the hell happens then
so
every time uh eric teaches me about
these uh
i don't know thresholds that we cross
yeah keep an eye on that siberian
methane
not that it's up to me by the way i was
just considering like
this thought would never have crossed
anybody's mind even like
50 years ago right i don't know it's
true think about the next generation
that's a good way to put it as well
as like yeah even if you're not going to
have kids
think about other people's kids all
right
crisis crisis crisis i think we'll just
call this uh
crisis colon a radical rethinking
and maybe we can like misspell crisis
like put some brackets or a slash in
there somewhere to make it like
we're playing on words use a tasteful z
that always helps oh that was really
90's right so i don't think that's cool
crises no that's true yeah crisis in
culture
something like that the crisis of crisis
anyway guys it was a great discussion um
i don't want to call this an
unstructured episode because that just
sounds like we're lazy
because we did do some preparation so i
think we'll call it these are a free
form
episodes where we don't have to an
emergence structure yeah we don't have
to do a whole bunch of research and
reading beforehand it's more like
what do you think about crisis
exactly what can what can phds or
soon-to-be phds think about or like come
up with on the spot
what can what we've already read
contributing
hopefully hopefully it wasn't all for
nothing i forget a lot of things but
it was yeah i hope it was fun for the
listeners um anyway we're gonna shut
down the recording
thanks eric matt and victor
uh we got a few episodes left before a
little bit of a christmas break
but i'll see you guys all next week
see you next time folks
you